est ce qu'on a vu rémy gaillard parvenir
à se faire passer pour un joueur de
lorient et sauver la fac on voit deux
trois trucs de rémy ça notre ami rémy
est dans les tribunes il a enfilé un
maillot qui n'est même pas le mot et il
va aller serrer la main au président de
la république qui d'après ce qu'il nous
a dit lui a dit qu'il avait très bien
joué ils descendent sur le terrain ils
passent les contrôles de sécurité
bibeau soulever la coupe mais moi ce qui
me tue c'est que même les joueurs de sa
personne même pas qui est un intrus au
milieu
moi je trouve ça extraordinaire et avec
un mythe un combat pour les animaux
d'avoir plein de vidéos de toi parce
qu'on te kiffe j'ai envie de voir plein
de trucs à l'epita surtout un combat
depuis des années tu te bats pour les
animaux on va le voir ton combat a pris
différentes formes
tu as effectué différentes démarches qui
a fait des trucs de ouf on va voir tous
ensemble et on tentera de récolter
encore des fonds pour son association
tafer animal parce que c'est hyper
important
l'aïe souligne on va faire des défis
pour pour récolter des sous alors dans
de nombreuses vidéos tu de grimm en
différents animaux comme tu l'as fait là
et tu fais vwazen ce qu'eux mêmes font
subir aux animaux et cie manière drôle
de dénoncer des choses et c'est pour ça
qu'on retient ce que ferrer me regarde
[Musique]
oh
les deux
bouh
[Musique]
c'est quoi mais le message que souhaite
faire passer là en fait là ya pas
vraiment de message c'est juste s'amuser
puis 4 ça parce que les hommes casqués
casser les bouts d'os d'animaux et
j'essaie souvent de renverser les
situations là exactement il ya il ya une
deuxième compile qu'on a fait regarde
assure toi et tu l'auras et après on va
voir que tu t'es mis dans une cage
ouais ça c'est un truc pour l'esprit
j'étais enfermé dans une cage à l'esprit
de montpellier dans le but de récolter
de l'argent pour l'association est fière
adopter les animaux tout en
sensibilisant donc à la cause animale
sont à voir juste après mais regardons m
2e compile de ré
il
[Musique]
le cas
un peu plus
[Musique]
il y aura d'abord hyper fan de bob
vraiment vous voulez nous dire un truc
non je veux redire ici
après c'est vrai donc tu t'es mis dans
une cage l'événement était filmée en
direct sur facebook ça va durer au total
81 6 heures enfermé dans cette cache
on a des images de toits regarde
[Musique]
brrr
j'ai l'habitude de faire des commissions
internet est en fait ce qui me tient
cette tour message
[Applaudissements]